[Music]  well Kerry just wrote a tell-all book  revealing shanna affair with Harrison  Ford that you almost caught them by the  way would you ever write they tell us  that I almost talked well I'm glad I  didn't  I was so self-involved at that point  they could have been doing it in front  of me and I wouldn't have noticed if I  was single and had my own agenda and I  like the sound of that  stop stop work well onset romances are  always their commonplace but it's kind  of tricky because if the relationship  doesn't last and they're on a TV series  and you have four more seasons ago I  mean it can be really awkward it  happened to me I'm happy that I was with  a girl that was on explain my sister on  a soap opera on General Hospital so but  I was blissfully unaware which was good  for me because I think it might have  been a distraction if I'd known oh  what's going on good they're they still  get along they're still like kissing  each other on stage  [Music]  you